October 23rd 2019 google announces it as
achieve the impossible goal of quantum
supremacy a machine more than 100
million times faster than your 16 inch
MacBook only one month later AWS
releases quantum computing as a service
in the cloud if you're a software
developer in today's world if there's a
good chance your infrastructure is on
the cloud and very likely with a big
provider like AWS Azure DCP or IBM 90%
of companies are on the cloud 60% of
workloads run on the cloud
30% of IT budgets are allocated to the
cloud generating hundreds of billions of
dollars in revenue and those numbers are
only expected to increase in the coming
years in today's video you'll learn
exactly what cloud computing is why
companies are adopting it so rapidly and
what you need to know as a software
developers if you're new here like and
subscribe and you can follow along with
the full write-up on fire ship i/o cloud
computing is a win win both for
companies that provide the services and
the companies that use them the
providers make tons of money in fact AWS
makes up more than 13% of Amazon's total
sales and operates at a much higher
profit margin than its retail business
but it's also a huge win for their
customers instead of buying and managing
its own hardware a start-up today has
all the infrastructure it could possibly
need right at its fingertips the startup
only pays for what it actually uses it
takes almost no effort to scale things
up or down and you don't need to hire an
IT guy to wire the thing up I mean
imagine if I tried to build a server
room here in Phoenix Arizona my
air-conditioning bill alone would likely
far exceed whatever my AWS bill would be
for the same set of resources that's
because they build these highly
optimized cloud campuses next to rivers
to optimize cooling with
state-of-the-art equipment that can
guarantee up times of 99.99% and beyond
I like to think of cloud computing like
a power plant you don't care where or
how that power is being generated you
just plug in your device and then pay
the bill in fact we might as well just
call that electricity as a service
because as a developer it's important to
distinguish between the different
categories of cloud services out there
the modern cloud can trace its roots
back to 2006 when Amazon launched ec2
and s3 ec2 stands for Elastic Compute
cloud and it's essentially a virtual
computer with its own RAM and CPU along
with an operating system you can
administer in an IP address for
networking when you spin up a server in
the cloud it's called a virtual machine
you
you haven't actually allocated any
specific piece of hardware rather the
cloud has virtualized a simulated
environment for you that resembles a
piece of hardware there's a lot going on
behind the scenes to make this possible
that you don't really need to know like
how they use hypervisors on top of bare
metal to handle CPU scheduling and
memory allocation the other big service
launched by AWS back in oh six was s3
which is basically a hard drive with a
file system in the cloud where you can
store things like images and videos
things like storage buckets and virtual
machines are known as
infrastructure-as-a-service they're the
low level building blocks of the cloud
so it's up to the developer to manage
and scale them once infrastructure
became available and created explosive
growth in a new type of software
software as-a-service
a great case study is Dropbox in the
early days the company didn't have the
money to roll out its own infrastructure
so it uploaded its users files to s3 so
it didn't even really start out as a
file storage company it was more of a
software company that helped people get
their files uploaded to the cloud and it
just goes to show you that you can build
a billion-dollar business by focusing
primarily on the front end user
experience so infrastructure as a
service abstracts away hardware it took
no more than a couple of years to see
cloud computing rise to another level a
platform as a service when developing an
application developers have a lot more
concerns than just hardware you have to
think about security and how to scale
the workload and how to put all the
pieces together into a cohesive unit
that's what a platform as-a-service aims
to do some famous examples include
elastic Beanstalk Heroku and Google App
Engine let's imagine a developer has
built an app with Ruby on Rails in order
to be used by people around the world at
that app we'll need a database and a web
server with a very specific
configuration the platform is designed
to take care of the configuration part
in theory the only thing that developer
has to do is upload their code and the
cloud takes care of the provisioning of
the database provides security and
scales the traffic so what we have here
is a platform for creating software as a
service but we can still take things one
step further the cloud can also provide
SDKs that bring the cloud directly into
our front-end applications and that
means a developer might not need any
back-end code at all
give us a back-end as a service the two
big players in this space include
firebase from Google and amplifi from
AWS with just a few lines of JavaScript
anybody can create a real-time
application
with user authentication hooked up to a
cloud database that's way more reliable
than any back-end you had built from
scratch sounds awesome but it's not
without its drawbacks the more you rely
on services offered by a given cloud the
more likely you are to experience vendor
lock-in the cloud can help you get your
software off the ground but once you
become successful like Dropbox your
opinion might start to change in 2016
Dropbox started to move their customers
data off AWS to their own data centers
and cut at least 75 million from their
operating expenses in this case it made
sense to move off the cloud to
on-premises but they're actually not
fully on-prem they still use the cloud
to handle about 10% of their file
uploads especially for edge cases and
regions that their data centers don't
cover and that's what we call a hybrid
cloud it generally refers to big
enterprises that run a private cloud on
their own data centers but also combine
it with services on the public cloud and
by public I mean the cloud where you can
just sign up with an email address and
credit card and start doing stuff you
might also hear the term multi cloud
this refers to a single architecture or
application that combines services from
multiple public clouds usually to
prevent things like vendor lock-in and
optimize pricing now let's go ahead and
jump into the cloud and take a look at
some of its capabilities we already
talked a little bit about virtual
machines and cloud storage buckets but
that's just the tip of the iceberg in
today's world
AWS alone offers more than a hundred and
fifty different services and api's but
one thing all these services share in
common is a service level agreement or
SLA this is a contract between you and
the cloud provider the provider
generally guarantees a certain uptime
and error rate for the service and will
generally provide a financial credit or
refund back to the client if it fails to
meet those SLA requirements on the other
side of the coin the client generally
has a quota that they must stay within
when using the service sometimes I like
to say the cloud scales infinitely but I
don't mean that to be taken literally
the quota tells you how far you can push
the limits when getting started with a
cloud provider a great place to start is
with Identity and Access Management the
opposite of Who am I I am it's the front
gate to your infrastructure and you
shouldn't just let anybody in you can
secure your services by attaching
security policies to them for example
you might have a storage bucket and that
policy controls who in the organization
can actually access the files inside it
now if your organization has thousands
of employees it would be very cumbersome
to manage policies for
every single resource that's where roles
come in they allow you to group
permissions together into a unit that
can be reused throughout the cloud and
you can assign roles outside of your
account if you're working with
consultants or some other third party
now in some cases your machines might
need to communicate with each other for
that you can define resource based
policies or service accounts this would
allow a virtual machine for example to
access a database somewhere else in your
cloud now that we know a little bit
about security let's take a look at the
backbone of the cloud compute resources
on Google cloud we can create a virtual
machine with compute engine it will give
you some options when you create this
machine the region represents the actual
physical location of the data center a
region closer to your end users should
be faster but some companies must follow
data residency regulations which dictate
where a customer data can actually be
stored now each region is actually a
campus with multiple isolated data
centers that means if you have a
mission-critical workload you can put it
in the same region in multiple zones if
a meteor destroys one of those data
centers you'll still have a reliable
service in that region that gives you
high availability and redundancy Asher
actually has the most data centers of
all the clouds and they have two secret
government locations that we don't even
know about the next option is the
Machine type which defines the amount of
memory and CPU in this virtual machine
the bigger they come the more they cost
but the great thing about the cloud is
that everything is pay-as-you-go you're
billed down to the second and you can
shut the instance off at any time from
there you need to determine the
operating system by selecting a disk
image you have a bunch of different
flavors of Linux or Windows to choose
from from there you can specify a
service account if you have other
services that need to access this VM by
default you have a firewall that makes
this instance inaccessible to the
outside world but we can change that by
allowing HTTP traffic now when it comes
to networking it's important to
understand that the instance has an
internal IP address and an external IP
address both of these values are
ephemeral or short-lived by default that
means if you rebuild the instance it
could be assigned a new IP address
however if you have a service that
relies on an IP address you can reserve
a static one so what's the difference
between an internal and an external IP
the internal version can only be used to
communicate with other compute instances
on the same cloud if you need to
communicate with others so
services on the Internet then you'll use
the external IP when it comes to
networking you might come across these
weird terms egress and ingress egress
defines outbound data that's being sent
from your instance to the outside world
ingress is the exact opposite data
that's being sent from the outside world
into your instance egress is typically
the one to watch out for because it can
have an impact on your bill now remember
we're just talking about a simulated
computer here if we want to access the
command line for that instance we can do
so directly in the console with a cloud
shell session and inside the session you
can do pretty much anything you could do
in a regular Linux or Windows terminal
so now that you know all this stuff
about virtual machines it's time to let
you in on a little secret for most
applications it's pretty rare to create
them manually like I just showed you
there's just better ways to handle your
compute resources and a lot of it has to
do with the way that they scale let's
imagine we built an app on this VM it's
popular and now our users are maxing out
the CPU and memory on the instance one
option would be to scale it vertically
we could do that by adding additional
CPU cores and more memory to make this
single VM more powerful but we can only
do that to a certain extent so another
option is to scale horizontally instead
of making our VM bigger we'll just
create more of them we can create them
in regions all over the world and then
distribute the workload accordingly when
you distribute vm's like this you also
need to worry about load balancing you
don't want all of your traffic going to
a single VM while the others are just
sitting there idle but all the clouds
offer load balancer services to help you
manage this stuff but what if you never
had to worry about scaling your
infrastructure at all well there are
actually already to cloud computing
paradigms that make that possible today
the first one we'll look at is
containerization now a container
provides a way for you to simulate an
operating system that may sound very
similar to a virtual machine but there's
one key difference you're inside a
simulation of a simulation inside
another giant simulation a virtual
machine sits on top of the hardware
directly but a container sits on top of
an underlying operating system to
simulate a nother operating system or
application this is a really awesome
thing for development because it means
you can put your application in a
container and then take it and deploy it
to any cloud you want or in other words
you avoid the vendor lock-in all of the
clouds have container registries where
you can upload your containers and then
use them
across other services now most companies
using the strategy have multiple
containers to run different services you
might have one container for your
node.js web server another for sending
email and another for training your
machine learning algorithms and as your
business becomes more complex you'll
need a way to orchestrate all of these
micro services and that's where
kubernetes comes in it organizes all of
your containers into groups of pods then
it can automatically scale those pods up
or down based on the amount of traffic
or utilization when the traffic goes up
kubernetes will allocate more virtual
machines to run more containers when the
traffic dies off it'll shut down those
virtual machines so they're not sitting
there idle costing you money but there's
a great saying about Kooper Nettie's and
it goes something like why you fin
around the kubernetes because in 2020 we
have server lists or functions as a
service it was first introduced in 2014
with AWS lambda it allows you to run
code in response to events like a
regular HTTP request or when something
happens and some other cloud service
like a write to the database the code
you deploy to one of these functions
will scale automatically so you never
have to worry about containers VMs or
anything like that and it's truly
pay-as-you-go because you only pay for
each individual function invocation now
prior to 2019 the big trade-off was that
you had no control over the actual
runtime so if you needed to install some
os-level software you wouldn't be able
to do that but just in the last year so
AWS released the runtime API and Google
released a service called cloud run and
that means today we can do pretty much
anything we want in a service
environment there are still some other
trade-offs but generally speaking it's
the easiest most cost effective way to
deploy back-end code that scales and I
think that's pretty much everything you
need to know about the compute and cloud
computing at least until we have quantum
computers in the cloud oh wait I almost
forgot it's 20/20 we have those things
already I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if you learned something
please like and subscribe and if you
want to see more videos like this let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]